put on your favorite blood death album
and sacrifice yourself to appease your
deadbeat dad because we have american
gods season 3
and there is a lot to talk about in this
video we'll be going into detail about
the final episode including some huge
reveals you may have missed including
who shadow moon really is
odin colluding with mr world and what
destiny has in store for laura and
shadow so grab your lucky coins and make
sure to like and subscribe because
here we go we start with eugenia the
woman who midwifed shadow moon
she has two coins in her eyes suggesting
she has passed on
my time on this earth is done we learned
in episode 7 that she's been a handful
since she got sick and we see her
taunting the yoruba god of death
aiku we'll see aiku in this clip wearing
a robe
bearing his name and on the back death
tour 2020
he takes his staff out of the fridge
which is the traditional staff aiku was
known to carry
also i'm known in my videos for getting
pronunciations wrong so apologies in
advance if i do that
eugenia tells an odd story of a hen that
always laid an egg with two yolks a
metaphor for shadow and his soulmate
being born as one but
separated bilquis is tasked with finding
shadow's other half as we see
imagery of shadow and laura merging as
one bilquis has been
on her own journey this season finding
out who she really is
as we'll find out later gods can forget
who they really
are sometimes this is caused by their
worshipers shifting the god to their
will
they create an identity an image
for us that serves them they teach us to
see ourselves through a veil
she tells shadow to smash that veil
hinting that he is blinded and does not
know his true identity
other gods like technical boy are also
not sure of who they really
are as mr world tells him later on every
time
technical boy evolves he essentially
loses the memory of his former version
his memories are
actually stored in a totem called
artifact number one
which mr world controls and keeps hidden
two miles underground
i believe this item here artifact number
one is a piece of flint signifying man's
first step toward technology
the creation of fire we'll later see
flashes of these
giant technological shifts where tech
boy evolved
such as the printing press light bulb
and nuclear bomb what i'm getting at
here is that there may be gods out there
who don't know that they are gods like
shadow moon laura and cordelia welcome
to the center of america motel
a place where gods can't harm one
another as we see when chernabog tries
to hit mr world with his mallet you'll
notice shadow asks ibis why wednesday in
mr world
didn't have their peace talks here
that's because wednesday knew he was
going to be killed it was all part of
his plan
in episode 6 we see mr world portrayed
here by actor danny trejo
talking to someone on the phone asking
what they should do about laura i
believe mr world here is talking to
wednesday
setting up his own assassination so he
can eventually evolve into a greater god
it is mr world after all who tells laura
where wednesday will be if the peace
talks took place at the motel here laura
wouldn't be able to kill him now you
might be asking yourself
why would mr world be colluding with
wednesday haven't they been fighting for
the past three seasons
well as it's heavily implied in the
final episode
mr world is the norse god loki the
trickster who feeds off chaos to become
more powerful
and what better way to sow chaos than
pitting the gods against one another so
loki here is just doing what's in his
best
interest by helping wednesday he ensures
greater chaos for the future
part of his trickster ways include being
able to shapeshift as we see with actors
danny trejo and dominique jackson
he also tricks technical boy who he
claims is arguably the most powerful god
into being imprisoned in his underground
vault part of technical boy's power
stems from the fact that he is the
embodiment of human innovation
making him the bridge between the old
gods and the new
this interaction between mr world and
technical boy is a callback to episode 5
at the chicago expo of 1893
in which we see a young technical boy
tricked by maximilian the illusionist
who is really mr world and what better
profession for this con man than a
magician
shadow remarks that wednesday's ravens
are with him now before cordelia arrives
and tells him that it was
laura who killed his father it's been
kind of an enigma as to what cordelia's
real identity is
the relationship she has with wednesday
is akin to a father-daughter more than
anything
however there are clues to suggest she
is the goddess frigg odin's wife
this radiant being is my fiance cordelia
she also wears a [ __ ] hat a symbol of
femininity and some also argue that of
caring compassion and love
and i'd also say cordelia is one of the
most caring characters this season
even choosing to see the good in
wednesday when others won't there's even
a moment wednesday refers to cordelia as
quote
my girl friday and the word friday is
derived from the goddess frigg this now
makes
four characters named after days of the
week if you also include a shadow moon
for monday
and tyr for tuesday as chinebach bangs
the receptionist
laura escapes through the ventilation
shaft and sees shadow he's having a
dream of his father
asking for help along with him are the
slaves we saw at the beginning of
episode 4.
this could also be a metaphor for the
potential threat the new gods shard
program will have on humanity
turning everyone into slaves the sharp
program would allow the gods the ability
to create a digital pipeline into every
cerebral cortex on the planet whoever is
in control of it would wield
unimaginable power
over the dead body of wednesday mr world
tells shadow that he had no part in
wednesday's death
he doesn't want to spark a war but we
know he secretly does
it's laura who lets everything out of
the bag how else did she get the coin to
retrieve odin's spear
how did she know where wednesday was
gonna be so she could kill him she
couldn't have done
it without help of course this doesn't
matter because by the time the old gods
would get their armies all gathered
shard will be completed and the old gods
will be forgotten
as is norse tradition it is up to the
sun to avenge a father's death meaning
shadow is expected to kill
laura this is something he doesn't end
up doing choosing to be a new leader one
that is better than his father
a leader of change later when we see him
strung up on the world tree yggdrasil he
has
visions of slaves picking cotton looking
up to him if i were to hazard a guess
shadow will become the god of change or
hope this makes even more sense
considering the show was written against
the backdrop of the 2019 presidential
election
the blm movement and various social
issues dividing america today
as stated earlier gods can morph and
change as time goes on
if that's the case and if shadow were a
god who did he derive from well we know
he's odin's son and the prevailing
theory out there is that he is balder
the god of light
joy purity and the summer sun the
requiem of baldr is also the name of the
song both laura and mr world hum
do you know what this song is it's like
who the [ __ ] are you so shadow believes
he has this destiny and decides to
undergo the vigil to look after his
father for nine days and nine nights
a feat of endurance mortals would die
from and even gods can barely endure
meanwhile laura experiences a prophetic
vision of shadow killed by odin spear a
hint of what's to come
this is followed by her visited by
bilquis both in person
and in a dream in this dream they kiss
and knowing bilquis's power of love
she's probably putting some sort of
spell on her
this is the last we see of these two for
the season so whatever bilquist is doing
here is setting us up for something
involving laura
and shadow's destiny as the vigil for
wednesday begins
shadow is approached by the three norns
women who tend to the world tree
also i should mention that chernabog is
uberpissed that shadow didn't avenge
wednesday by killing laura and this will
undoubtedly be a point of contention in
season 4 considering he even says he'll
kill
shadow for it shadow is washed with what
the norns call the hot water of time
washing away his past and preparing him
for his future
a not so subtle nod that he'll be
evolving into something new
and it's a hard day of work for these
actresses who have to rub ricky whittle
in
oils meanwhile at mr world's
headquarters technical boy has gone mad
in his search for artifact number one
he's even taken to consuming raw data he
was told that this artifact would help
restore him
and stop him from glitching a glitch
which occurred way back
in episode 1 when he touched bilquis
we'll later see technical boy
haunted by billquist or rather a
manifestation of his own subconscious
technical boy says that's impossible he
doesn't have a subconscious he's
technology after all but this
subconscious tells him that the only way
to overcome this glitch
is for him to embrace his emotions this
evolution of technical boy could be
pointing to the fact that technology
will one day get to the point where
robots and ai
have realistic emotional responses just
like humans
so it makes sense that technical boy
will reach that point as well
as shadow undertakes the vigil he
experiences several visions and voices
soraya telling him to follow the night
sky when he can't find his way
the yoruba god yamoja saying that
they've been awaiting his arrival
and laura telling him he's going to die
we also get this flaming bison buffalo
who apparently is important in the book
but has just kind of been this unknown
eye candy figure for
three seasons shadow awakes on a plane
across from wednesday a call back to the
first time he met wednesday back in
season one
he says they're currently in a place
between the living and the dead and
shadow learns the harsh truth that this
was all part of wednesday's plan
for his own son to sacrifice himself for
him
a blood sacrifice by a son wow
that's powerful enough to restore me to
all my former glory
wednesday needed a martyr to return him
to his former glory
and what better person than his own son
it makes sense almost every character on
the show has said the same thing about
wednesday that he only does things in
his own
self-interest just before his death tyr
even tried to warn shadow
the death i give you will be a mercy
compared to your
[Music]
so does this mean that shadow is dead
absolutely not
we've already seen multiple characters
come back from the dead including laura
who's come back twice
and with all this talk of destiny it's
clear shadow has a much larger role to
play but it looks like wednesday will be
returning in a far
more powerful form we see the shroud
covering his body blow into the wind
where his body has disappeared
plus these large storm clouds in the
distance heralding his arrival
and perhaps ragnarok ibis after all
remarks that this could be the beginning
of
something much worse shadow's death
mimics what happens to baldur in norse
mythology
loki is instrumental in balder's death
just as mr world is two shadows
plus balder's wife aka laura is
instrumental in resurrecting him
something we'll likely see in season
four balder's death is also considered a
harbinger for ragnarok so these are some
pretty big clues as to who shadow really
is and where the show is headed but what
did you guys think of the season i want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below
thanks for watching everyone for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much